the Ukrainian president has spoken to
the security Council before but this was
his first appearance in person
and the Russian Ambassador objected
strongly to the fact that Vladimir
zelenski was listed as the first Speaker
an objection sharply struck down by the
sessions chairman there is a solution
for this
if you agree you stop the war and
president zielinski will not take the
floor
set an abrasive tone for the session
and the Ukrainian president was deeply
critical of the security council's
inability to hold Russia to account
calling for an end to the Russian veto
power
these are the situations that have
changed everything for the UN we should
recognize that the UN finds itself in a
deadlock on the matters of aggression
political theater continued as a Russian
Ambassador appeared at his phone
throughout zielinski's speech then after
the Ukrainian president left the Russian
foreign minister arrived and it was the
turn of the Ukrainian delegation to gaze
at their phones during his speech the
foreign minister repeated his contention
that Ukraine was little more than a U.S
puppet
I would like to remind the distinguished
secretary of state that President
zielinski signed a decree prohibiting
the conduct of negotiations with the
government of Vladimir Putin if the U.S
is so interested in them I don't think
it would be very difficult to give the
command for the decree of zelenski to be
lifted this after the U.S Secretary of
State had made his anger at Russia clear
it's hard to imagine a country
demonstrating more contempt for the
United Nations and all that it stands
for
this from a country with a permanent
seat
on this Council
President Putin is betting that if he if
he's doubling down on the violence
that if he's willing to inflict enough
suffering
on enough people
the world will cave on its principles
and Ukraine will stop defending itself
the Secretary General summed up the
opinion of many U.N members Russia's
invasion of Ukraine in clear violation
of the United Nations chart at an
international law
is aggravating geopolitical tensions and
divisions threatening Regional stability
increasing the nuclear threat
and creating deep fissures in our
increasingly multi-polar worlds
but to the Russian veto in place there's
nothing the security Council can do
about it the special debate began in the
morning and continued until the early
evening and it's still not over some
speakers will return to make their
points in the course of Thursday but
this is just an indication of how the
situation in Ukraine has utterly
dominated this United Nations General
Assembly
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera at the United
Nations